now we have okay so we can have
discussion questions for half now this
is your moment
yes
I think about 10 years ago there was a
non-profit founded in Andhra Pradesh for
a garcia and they were providing rural
children with science education in a
very imaginative format they had these
big buses and hands-on learning tools
that the bus drivers were equipped with
and they would drive to the rural areas
and invite the kids to come and
experiment and this has really resulted
in quite a large section of neglected
rural schools getting access to actual
very simple science experiments and some
of those children would come through
that have actually gone on to win Intel
scholarships I'm not aware of the sudden
and thank you for letting me introduce
you to the founder and campus in just
outside of time for the question
I this is really fascinating actually
some experience volunteering it a bunch
for king of schools and I think kind of
listening to the history and seeing some
of the quotes kind of put it in
perspective
oh so the places where I've been and
this is the Marshall and then there's
some other schools like that pear
identity is a big part of like the
alternative space like the identity of
the community where the students are
coming from so in the kind of present
day context means like do the students
like we talked talked well do they talk
about that aspect of it like their
identity and how you know kind of focus
on that was whether you know like how
integral it goes to their education um
over these three schools that I have
discussed the only place where the
identity question comes up very strongly
is of course carnival which is the the
tribal school in why not area where KJ
baby actually focuses on the skills of
the why not tribals foreground that then
took them around as a performing troupe
and so on so forth so the was and and he
himself used this very interesting
phrase of their education actually
beginning with them beginning to respect
themselves and this he saw the very
crucial necessity in the process that he
enabled at carnival so that is one of
the few locations where that is for
grounded otherwise one does not hear
because they were single more or less
homogeneously low cost and low class of
course one doesn't hear within the ocean
is called a school space or any form of
you know obviously this
in the classroom but also any heightened
sort of realization of cosmas in the
schools or in the schooling system it's
only in the community that they
experience this and interestingly enough
many of these faces did not actually
think it fit for necessary to form
around questions of caste in discussions
within the classroom there were
discussions if you see for instance the
material that Margaret has put together
about color and gender difference and so
on so forth but the cosmas caste
question
very rarely came up because they were
all uniformly from a particular
background so I don't know and so when
the question of course actually comes up
it is in the situation where there with
other castes mostly in the government
school setting where the both experience
and also learn from being in a multi
cast more of that happen in kind of the
tribal setting because the school that I
where I think they were trying to kind
of differentiate from like the the
larger in the society around them and
you know some of those practices kind of
dominating what used to be a way of life
but we're in the kind of the more where
they were kind of more the lips and more
that question of identity wasn't as
strong in the intention of the person
organizing and running the school itself
as I said baby saw a need for some kind
of education like those among tribals
and needs it's a conscious effort to
foreground that identity in the very
school space itself so it's not like
there was any attempt to pretend that it
was you know where that fact the tribal
identity would have to be masked in
order for
the education to be him because they
consciously attempt to program that as
something to be proud of
rather than being ashamed of which as
you know was the experience of charge
equals my quoted from at length so I
would say that's the difference
the other two schools did not fall
around the question of cost or yes cost
especially they did not feel a necessity
perhaps because of the setting in which
they won was Islam
the other was village they didn't feel
that as I sit here
to go back to your main concern about
regular public schooling and alternative
schooling see that the problem seems to
be divided seems to be that there has to
be a certain kind of public
certification of education which the
formal school system would university
system provides but there are at least
from what you described and seem to be
two kinds of sources of distrust where
the credibility of this public
certification is put into question one
is a distrust by certain segments of the
market itself right where for instance
various kinds of employers may not have
the confidence in the school or
university certificate and would insist
on some other kind of test so for
instance the face-to-face interview is
something like that where which
basically says we don't really trust so
there's one kind of source of lack of
confidence but the other one which your
relative schooling seems to suggest
which is not so much on the part of the
market or segments of the market but a
sense amongst certain indicators that
the formal schooling does not provide
what it does not give you real education
so there is some notion of a real
education which is bigger and that seems
to be what these ordinary school seems
to do because they don't as described
they don't seem to prepare this to any
better
for employment or anything like that so
if those are the two resources of
distrust then given the situation now
where what you're suggesting is that
this right the private education largely
seems to be directly at precisely get
acquiring those kinds of skills which
the formal school system only at least
the government school system does not
provide so whether it's English language
trading or whatever else which of course
makes much more expensive it's a
transaction so is that the sort of
moment that we read know in other words
it's either the private schooling or
it's the same public credentials those
who cannot afford the expenses of
certification and essentially that
government sector where the university
is acceptable oh there are two things I
want to see you know one is that
actually I would disagree that the
private education efforts that we are
exposed to today are providing anything
better than the government school system
they are not necessarily doing so I am
suggesting in fact that there is a vast
market in credentialing which is being
exploited by the private education
sector so there is no real education
actually lancets happening so so the
choice is really between what is the
better credentials because government
schools have been seen as spaces which
are exclusively now confined to people
no class definitely they are to be
avoided and therefore the chancel
perhaps becoming even slightly more
acceptable in see the job market or some
kind of a sketch ability is happening
while private schooling but that is an
expression of hope rather than actual
reality that's what I am suggesting I
mean the report after report is showing
that it's not just government schools
that are failing us today it is also the
vast network of private schools and
believe me there also as you probably
already know in villages as well then
losses are no longer exempt from the the
the market or the educational market as
it where having said that I also want to
come back to this question of whether or
not the alternative school actually
prepared students for the exam but the
most interesting thing about it is that
these students were able to take the
exam with a year or less of preparation
in most cases and talk about the seven
Senate exam but in in some cases also
the Tencent exam with a year or less
preparation showing that actually
passing exam does not require ten years
of schooling or seven years or seven or
eight years Cooley
rather you can't spend that time doing
things that you enjoy and probably gain
confidence the whale which many
testified to the question of confidence
or learn some other skills and so on
but that you can actually take an exam
which entitles you to whatever the
privileges of taking the exam are in a
relatively short period of time for
preparation they were wide u so that is
the case I am sorry to interrupt in this
way but it really interests me because
I'm also involved in this kind of stuff
why do you think that is the case that
you can prepare for an exam
partly because the skills that they have
been equipped with stand them in good
state and partly because frankly they
can set aside certain kinds of ideas of
Education that they received through the
alternative school and be able to simply
master what is required of them for the
public exam and they do it I mean in
some ways they are the proof that you do
not require vast a very long period of
schooling in order to reach that stage
you need basic literacy you need basic
numeracy but thereafter it is individual
effort with some of course teacher input
as well and sustained effort for a short
period of time to prepare for the exam
you are actually working backwards
what's the exam like and you work for
backwards to prepare for so that would
would actually explain why this happens
you should continue answering this
question no so my you are absolutely
right when you say that there is
distrust both on the outside of the
educational system and within but I
think the moment at which we are act is
a frightening one because I think in for
the most part parents particularly of
those who come from poorer backgrounds
have more or less relinquished the idea
of actually learning the more or less
entirely are focused on the questions of
credentialing and one sees this actually
and I'm sure many of you in this room
would have seen it in a similar
circumstance when you take interviews
for jobs in colleges and universities
that people come along with you know
various kinds of credentials and
studying seems to be one way of keeping
yourself occupied until you get a job so
you acquire degree after degree people
with multiple entrance
sometimes even double PhDs but have
really nothing to show for it by
actual reflection education on
intellectual engagement so that is rapid
and I think we are we're really not even
aware the scale of this kind of thing
except from these reports but that's I
want to ask a question before thank you
so much for this first of all because I
think you've you've raised some very
personal questions and maybe one of the
reasons for the silence initially after
your talk is because we are all
educators and in some ways this is what
we do and you're really asking us to
think much much more broadly here we are
sitting at an exclusive institution that
absolutely regulates who can be within
the space of the institution and outside
of it so I think you're posing some very
very profound questions about other
kinds of possibilities but as you say
the time of democracy but it's also
another kind of time so thank you so
much for this I think it's just a deeply
moving talk but the question I have for
you is the dark space that you took us
to which is if Ramaiah says with the DSS
this is the real university or not and
sort of a or a number of people right
the street is my University and so on
and that this is a place of real
education and you've kind of brought us
to the present where you talk about
credentialing and the fact that
everybody in some sense has given up on
the real education within the classroom
I guess the question that I want to ask
you which kind of takes you outside of
your talk is who is then the Dalit
student in the multi cast classroom
today so if she is in that space and I'm
just sort of picking up on what you said
about either the space that some of
these students were in where they were
tremendously sort of
Siddhant and who they became
self-respect as we said because they
were in spaces of kind of chosen or not
chosen segregation right which actually
was a was an enabling space for them or
they were at a particular historical and
political moment where the university
came together with let's say DSS for
political awakening if we're not in that
moment anymore now oh yeah I agree then
the question is who is that the next
student in that multicast classroom and
what does she do there is she there
merely to say I am in this I mean does
it become a kind of insurgence of
presence does she force another kind of
knowledge on the classroom as a whole
just what are the possibilities from
within the context of the classroom
space for in any way pursuing the kind
of the place that you left us in which
is the question of real education and
because this is such a contentious issue
not just in elementary school and so
forth clearly in the context of the
University I'm just wondering what you
think is happening in those multi multi
class classrooms today because they're
such broad spaces of spaces where there
is an intensive unspoken conversation
around sexuality desire so what what is
the space of that classroom today oh I
guess the short answer is no and I think
the reason I see this so bluntly is
because one of the things I am
suggesting is the government classroom
particularly in say the urban areas but
increasingly also in rural areas and
I'll come to that one instance again in
a moment are not anymore multi class
the upper castes have more or less
entirely withdrawn and have exercised
the privilege of going to you've done it
some withdrawing it's not as it lets out
many but the minute they can afford
something even slightly better they
themselves are withdrawing from these
phases so it's really only those who can
afford absolutely nothing else nothing
better who are in that space and who
receive actually most of the most
appalling decree of inattention I would
say so I am suggesting that P you know
the term I use which is actually a Dewey
phrase it's George Dewey's phrase
socially those muscles which is enabled
is something that is certainly still
true over public university and that is
what is of course now rapidly being the
cycle so we're going to weigh in the
university the way the dublin school had
already gone after the 1980s I would say
the eighties would be the time when the
shift really happened when this
extraordinary proliferation of private
schooling happens there are these
exceptions which for instance she had
mentioned in algebra creation so on
there is one person on across the issues
training the shaking costs very
rigorously is 90's officer and he has
managed to get a lot of history and he
is again focusing over self-respect he
apparently struts around the school with
guns on his two sides of his hip and he
asserts this kind of military training
for these children many of whom have
never done mission in Azim trade
University in Bangalore through
scholarships and so on so forth so there
are these is small exceptions but by and
large the government school is one which
has been deserted by the upper class and
has been given up so I would not say
that there is there is much out there
where there are multi cost classrooms as
I as in a school I visited in right too
recently I only just visited
the place which has both children of the
indices and limits for the land owning
casts the rigidity of the difference is
not so much in the classroom and in the
access to education but around midday
meals key now see here again you see
this this kind of extraordinary politics
kay the ground with Dainius which are of
course a major reason for students at
all and here tending these government
schools it's all the meal and the
insistence that it be an envelope who
cooks and that the Dalit students
separately and the United States
separately and so on all these things
are somehow reproduced in ways that are
almost naturalized you know so so to the
extent that there I mean I'm not saying
that there was a better moment we don't
know certainly the stories of
humiliation that these other guys would
feels testify to suggest something else
but there is a to the extent that there
are multi class classrooms at all there
are all kinds of new divisions which are
not necessarily signs of encouragement
so I think what we are fearing is that
and it's it's amazing because you know
this is this is an area where the that
it says our sympathy was at one time
very very strongly problem no longer it
doesn't exist a social force in the same
way that produces this new socialization
to which I refer now take the last
question and that's Gary wish for
nothing
thanks so much for this presentation
Jenna Kealey in fact it was exactly this
issue of midday meals that I wanted to
also ask you about because it really I
think if enlarged is that context of
relationship between schools the
alternative schools and the states and
of course the midday meals as you
rightly pointed out have become highly
politicized but I I recall that the you
know that the emergence of private
efforts such as in Karnataka role played
by emphasis a few years ago where they
were participating in schemes for midday
meals and then they did studies which
showed that students were staying in
schools much more than had been the case
previously and I was struck actually by
some of the images that you had or the
graphs that you have shown where there's
some correlation between oh not
correlation but the fact that they even
the alternative schools were not able to
retain students within this within the
schools for various fact for for various
reasons but they brought a question that
I wanted to ask you was really what you
might have to say about the role played
by special interest groups alternative
schools and I mentioned the role played
by emphasis in the midday meals which
contributed to as they put it you know
retention of school students within
schools but it did raise this very
nagging question about how if the if the
states have surrendered their
obligations to provide the kinds of
education that students need to compete
effectively in the workplace are these
our special interest groups actually
stepping into a vacuum that
is then you know directed by motivations
that have very little to do with you
know benign you know benign reasons and
may in fact contribute to a much more
partisan type of education so I was
actually interested to hear you speak to
that issue which is perhaps even more
unsettling for those of us who have been
watching the rise and even fall of some
of these alternative schools so if I
understood you correctly you're asking
how we assess the new interest of say
corporate outfits like emphasis at least
coming from Grinnell the group that is
most interested in primary education is
Azim Premji and their efforts in
schooling and there are very serious
which are being need to supplement what
is actually happening in the government
school system they are in fact actually
supporting so I would not see it as a
troubling development I would see it as
something quite useful and necessary and
I think the foundation has recognized
that so they have supported actually
some of the alternative education
networks if I can continue with the
story of Margaret whom I referred to
throughout this talk she has moved to a
village in Richard and his start ed has
started a school so this is what many of
those who ran alternative schools are
doing we are supplementing what happens
in Dublin schools they run classes from
seven to ten the child then goes to the
other government school from 10:00 to
3:30 and they come back to this extra
classroom again till about 5:30 or 6:00
so they get the Supplemental education
which is actually the place for most of
the education
because nothing much is happening with
it so you stay enrolled in the
government school for the purpose of
your midday meal and for the purpose of
getting the degree but the actual
education is happening through these
minor kinds of efforts to supplement and
allene fringy is actually supporting
that in a major way because it
recognizes that this is what the need of
the are is you can't really set up at
school but you can certainly supplement
it and this is something that they
they're not only supporting these
efforts but the education program they
run in their university is also geared
towards producing the kinds of mid-level
administrators of that kind of program
so there is a sustained interest in is
this plan is I think to start in the 600
of the streets of India at least 200
mystics should have one such as if any
kind of interventions goal so I'm not
actually aware because the Infosys
staying in bed intervention that I know
of is in the grant of computers which I
have seen they have given to many
schools including some of our schools to
which I referred in the last lecture
that is a that's a bit of a funny
business because it looks like it's
machines which they don't necessarily
use anymore or find you know saleable or
anything like that which have been
beamed out all these if I could if I can
just add to that very quickly since you
asked about emphasis so this is a few
years ago or not I never moti was still
early
emphasis and at that point he was
actually very interested in bringing
villagers to the emphasis campus and
discussing with them you know the types
of schools that he able to assist with
but he was also very clear that in fact
he was confirmed by the villagers were
they were asking for instruction in
English yes this is the building
yes that's what I said I have my voice
now my question will keep it's a much
smaller question so this obviously was a
very interesting talk because the
discussion this is the first time in my
life that I as moderator have my
question
[Music]
[Applause]